[Inaudible].
Imagine you're out for a blissful swim,
trying to catch a glimpse of some beautiful whales.
The sun is shining. The water feels refreshing and Oh,
something just brushed past your leg.
Something slimy, slithery,
something really, really big.
A giant squid has decided your next meal.
How did a giant squid get the drop on you?
Are you going to be next on the dinner menu and how
can your measly two arms take on
this is what if,
and here's what would happen if you were attacked by a giant squid,
Giant squids are one of the ocean's most enduring mysteries.
They live in the deepest waters of the ocean and are rarely seen by humans.
In fact,
most of the stuff we do know about them is from dead carcasses that wash
onto shore, like it's smaller relatives.
The giant squid has two eyes, a beak, eight arms,
two feeding, tentacles, and a siphon,
all stuff you don't want swimming up against you. Giant squids,
mostly eat deep water fishes and other squids,
including going full on Hannibal Lecter and eating their own kind.
And they do not mess around. In fact,
they're known to attack entire schools of fish from below.
Once they grab a meal with the suckers on their feeding tentacles,
they drag the prey down to their sharp beak.
This cuts the prey into more manageable pieces.
And as if you weren't already too scared to ever go swimming again,
they start doing even more damage.
The giant squid then uses its Wrangler,
which is like a tongue covered with teeth.
This slices and dices,
the prey up into even tinier bite-sized pieces. Dinner is served.
Maybe you should get out of the water like right now,
if you're unlucky enough to be hunted by a giant squid,
I've got some bad news for you. The giant squids, sheer size strength,
speed,
and hunting abilities would make it extremely difficult to escape.
The first stealthy move it would make is attacking you from below
horrifying, right? Well, it gets worse. The giant squid,
probably isn't going to devour you right then there,
it's going to drag you into deep water where it feels safe from its own
predators, because it's so fast,
you would definitely struggle with the changing pressure and your eardrums
would certainly burst this speedy whiplash may also break some of your
bones from the giant squid, holding you so tight.
If you're somehow not dead by being gripped and scraped by the feeding
tentacles,
the giant squid would use a whole of its arms to bring you to its beak.
If you're at this stage, the hope of escape is pretty non-existent.
The giant squid is using all of its strength to pull you in for dinner.
And I know it's a bad time to say this, but.
It won't be a quick death.
You see giant squids have a bit of a gag reflex problem.
So they're going to eat you nice and slow.
This is it. You close your eyes and prepare to be squid food.
Wait, what's that sound?
Yeah, your buddy, the sperm whale has come.
To the rescue. Now.
Giant squids don't have much in the way of predators, but sperm whales.
Yeah. They stay away from those guys.
Researchers have found giant squid beaks in the stomachs of sperm,
whales and battle wounds from giant suckers on their bodies.
This means that your new best friend has a taste for supersized
calamari, the giant squid. Isn't going down without a fight though,
and we'll go toe to toe with the sperm whale.
Now I know it would be super cool to watch,
but I think you're forgetting something you're still under water.
If by some miracle,
you make it back to landed one piece and you're going to have quite the story to
tell it's a shame. No one will ever believe you.
This is because giant squid sightings,
let alone attacks are so rare.
We still have so much to learn about them.
There could be millions of them lurking in the deep waters and we wouldn't even
know. And well beyond them,
there could be tons of other creatures,
lurking and unexplored parts of the ocean.
The good news is it can't get any worse than a giant squid,
right? Oh, geez. I really got to stop jinxing myself.
What if the cracking was real?
Wow, that's a story or another, what is.